وصفت بالاكثر تدميرا في تاريخ اسرائيل
وبالتالي اثارت غضب الكثيرين في الشارع
وفي المعارضه نتحدث هنا عن الميزانيه
الجديده لاسرائيل الميزانيه اقرها الكنيست
باغلبيه 64 نائبا من اصل 120 هم اعضاء
الكتله اليمنيه لنتنياهو بلغت الميزانيه
484 مليار شيكل لعام 2023 اي نحو 130
مليار دولار وفي عام 2014 ستكون الاكبر في
تاريخ اسرائيل ستزيد نصف ترليون شيكل لاول
مره بالمصادقه عليها ضمنه حكومه نتنياهو
استقرارا داخليا حيث اخضع رئيس الوزراء
لمساومات من قبل الاحزاب المتشدده في
الائتلاف الحكومي ولذلك كان نتنياهو سعيدا
ولا يوجد جدول الدينات الحكومه برئاسه
لديها اخبار رائعه لمواطني دوله اسرائيل
نجحنا بتمرير قانون الميزانيه لسنتي 2003
و2024 ما يمنح الاستقرار والبناء لدولتنا
ويعطينا الاستقرار في السياسه لاربع سنوات
قادمه وهذا امر مهم
الاستقرار الذي وفرته الميزانيه لنتنياهو
غائب عن الشارع الاسرائيلي المنتفض منذ
فتره زعيم المعارضه وصف الميزانيه الجديده
بالاسوا والاكثر تدميرا في تاريخ اسرائيل
وبالتالي انطلق المتظاهرون في الشوارع
للتعبير عن غضبهم رؤوا في الميزانيه مهبل
للدوله وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بتخصيص مساعدات
ماليه لليهود المتشددين بمئات الملايين من
الدولارات واللافتات واضحه مشاهدينا كما
نشاهد لن ندعك تساعد في تدمير اسرائيل هذه
رساله المتظاهرين لينه ياهو
هذه اشكاليه كبيره الميزانيه تهدف الى
تقسيمنا لمنح المقربين من الحكومه اموالا
وليس للقطاعات الاخرى المحتاجه ليس للصحه
وليس للتعليم ولا للاكاديميين بل لادامتي
عدم المساواه
الميزانيه هائله فهي تمنح امتيازات
لقطاعات معينه ولا تاخذوا عامه السكان في
الاعتبار لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج وال
قصص وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات